J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK,
welcome back.
I hope you had a good break.
Can you remember back to when
we, before break, what we were
talking about?
The last thing we did was this
gyroscope bicycle-wheel
precession to show what would
happen to a nucleus that was
spinning in a magnetic field, or
an
electron for that matter.
Just to rehearse it a little
bit, remember the idea of a
pulse, a 90 degree pulse, that
if you have a big magnetic
field-- the blue one there,
really enormous--
and then the little magnet of
the nucleus precesses at 100
MHz, for example, in a certain
field.
And that gives rise to a
constant vertical field, but a
rotating horizontal field from
that one.
So the question is whether that
rotating horizontal
field, which as you see it will
be going back and forth
and back and forth, will act as
an antenna
and give you a signal.
You should be able to pick up a
radio
signal at 100 MHz.
Indeed, you should be able to,
except that there's not just
one proton.
There are lots of protons, and
they're in different phases of
precession.
So although they all add
vertically, and you have a
substantial vertical magnetism
from those, their horizontal
components cancel, so you don't
see anything.
In fact, the energy is so small,
of the interaction of
each of these magnets with the
field, that there are ones
pointing the opposite direction,
with higher energy,
almost exactly the same
population.
Just a tiny, tiny difference.
But we'll look just at the
excess.
Obviously, ones down will cancel
ones up.
But if we look just at the net
ones up, even they cancel,
because they're at different
phases of rotation or
precession about that axis.
But you can do a trick.
We could consider that we're
rotating with them, so that they
look like they're
standing still.
And then in our frame we'll put
on a little bit of a
magnetic field that's
horizontal, a very weak field.
And now, as far as we can see,
we don't care about the big
field anymore, because we've
compensated for it by orbiting
around this thing as we're
looking at it.
But what we see is that these
will begin to process in our
frame around that horizontal
field, so they'll do a slow
precession, all of them, in that
direction.
So they'll be going like this.
They'll start here, they'll go
there, then they'll go down,
then they'll go back, and then
back up again.
But we're going to put on a
pulse only long enough, of
this field, so that they go down
to here.
That's called a 90 degree pulse,
and they'll
rotate down like that.
And now forget the rotating
frame.
They'll look like they're just
pointing out toward us in the
rotating frame.
But if we go back to the real
frame, the laboratory frame,
what we see is this whole bunch
precessing around the field.
And now as they precess around
the field in the laboratory
frame, there will be a net
horizontal field that they're
generating, a magnetic field.
And that will be the antenna
that broadcasts a signal that
we can hear.
And what will determine the
frequency of that signal
that's going to be coming out
from going back and forth, and
back and forth or around?
What will its frequency be?
How rapidly are they precessing?
It says 100 MHz.
And what determined the 100 MHz?
The strength of this big
magnetic field.
Remember, the more you twist on
something,
the faster it precesses.
So we could make it 100 MHz.
If we had half as big a big
field, it'd be 50 MHz.
Or twice the field, it would be
200 MHz, and so on.
So we get a signal that's 100
MHz radio frequency in
the laboratory frame, that we
could detect with an antenna.
But in time it will relax.
This is a non-equilibrium
situation when we put the
energy in to make it go down.
And in time it'll come back to
equilibrium.
And that process is called
relaxation.
And there are various things
that control
how fast that happens.
But it will reestablish
equilibrium, and it will be
very important later in the
lecture about this relaxation,
and you'll see why.
So a 90 degree pulse makes the
spinning nuclei, protons, or
C-13s broadcast a frequency that
tells what their local
magnetic field is.
The higher the field, the faster
they precess, the
higher the frequency.
Now let's first look at this as
it arises in magnetic
resonance imaging, where the
purpose is to locate protons
within the body using a
non-uniform magnetic field.
Now, the idea of tomography is
important here.
I've taken this from a Colorado
Physics 2000-page.
So this is a slice through
somebody's body, show their
rib cage, spine, and so on, and
they're wearing some sort
of jacket that's opaque to
X-rays.
And we're interested in finding
what it looks like
inside, where these things are.
So what we do is we take X-rays,
and send an X-ray beam
straight through and see how
much gets through.
And we scan the X-ray from top
to bottom, and see how much
gets through at every different
x-coordinate.
So we do a scan, and it starts
at the top, but oops, there's
something there.
And there's even more there.
And lots, then a little bit
more.
And for when we hit the spine
there's going to be quite a
bit, and so on.
But that's just a
one-dimensional
picture of the density.
Now what we're going to do is
take that same picture and
just smear it out to the right.
So that's the profile, top to
bottom, or stomach to back, of
this particular slice through
the body of bones
or whatever it is.
Now the neat trick is that you
rotate that,
rotate it by 15 degrees.
And now do the same thing again,
and superimpose the new
one on the old one.
And now rotate another 15
degrees and do the same trick,
scan top to bottom and add it
up.
And do it again, and again, and
again, and again, and
again, again, again, and again.
And see what you got now?
When you superimpose all those,
you get what it looked
like, the two-dimensional slice
through the thing.
So that's called tomography.
If you can get a one-dimensional
projection,
and do it in lots of different
directions and add them
together, you can get the
two-dimensional, or in fact, a
three-dimensional picture of
what's going on inside.
So that's the trick that's used,
except you want to do it
for protons, not for bone.
So we want to find protons in
the body.
For example, let's find where
there's fluid
water in the body.
So there's a body, and we put it
inside this cylinder and
wrap the cylinder with special
wire, that if we cool it to
liquid helium temperature is
superconducting.
So essentially, we've made a big
solenoid magnet that goes
along the body's axis.
Now, what will happen?
Well, suppose that field is 1.5
Tesla, which
means 15,000 Gauss.
A Gauss, you remember, is about
the size of the earth's
magnetic field more or less, so
15,000 times as strong as
the earth's magnetic field.
So what will happen to the
protons in there?
Well, they're going to precess.
And in that field, at 15,000
Gauss or 1.5 Tesla, they'll
precess at 63 MHz.
So if we put an antenna in there
and give a 90 degree
pulse, we're going to hear a
signal at 63 MHz.
Our radio will pick that up.
So we know there are protons in
the body.
Surprised?
No.
The question is, where are the
protons in the body?
Now here's an analogy to figure
this out.
Suppose we had a cricket in this
room, and
wondered where it was.
But I'm blind.
I can hear, but with only one
ear, so I can't hear it.
I don't have spatial resolution
with my ear.
How can I find out where the
cricket is in this room?
Anybody got an idea?
Well, I have one bit of control
over the room.
I can make a temperature
gradient in the room, make it
cold in front and warm behind.
Suppose I can do that.
Now how can I find the cricket?
What?
Derek?
STUDENT: Crickets chirp at
different speeds at different
temperatures. and
different intervals.
PROFESSOR: You hear it chirping.
You count how many there are in
13 seconds and add 40.
You establish a temperature
gradient and you
listen with a stopwatch.
And if you go to Snopes, you can
see that this is not an
urban legend or a rural legend.
It's true that you can do that.
And they actually show this
picture of Doctor LeMone from
Boulder, Colorado, who actually
did this with
crickets, and showed that it
gives a very good measure of
the temperature.
So if I could establish a
temperature gradient from
front to back, and count for 13
seconds and add 40, and
knew what the temperature was,
I'd know how far
from front to back.
What would I do next if I want
to find the cricket?
I'd fiddle with the air
conditioning controls and make
a temperature gradient from left
to right.
I could even make one from top
to bottom, and then I'd
know what its x-, and its y-,
and its z-coordinates are.
So I could find the cricket that
way.
So we're going to do the same
thing with the protons in the
water in the body.
So back to the body here.
What I need is not a uniform
field where all the protons
are going at 63 MHz.
I want to make them faster in
some regions than others.
So what I do is I put two coils
around this solenoid.
And in the one near the head, I
make the current go that
way, which reinforces the field.
And in the one near the feet I
make it go that way, which
subtracts from the field.
So now I've generated a gradient
along the body.
And it turns out to be that
what's actually used is about
40 microtesla per millimeter.
So if I went, like, 25
millimeters, about an inch,
that would be 1000 microtesla,
that is a millitesla.
So it'd be about one part in
15,000.
Or, pardon me, one part--
it's a millitesla out of a 1.5
tesla, so about a part per
1000 difference.
So that means if I slice the
body there or there, on the
first slice--
remember, there's is a gradient
from foot to head--
so there we have the average.
63 MHz is going to be a signal
coming out from protons
that are in that first slice.
But in the second slice they're
going to be at 63.05,
about a part per 1000, because
there's a higher
field near the head.
And if I did another slice
another inch or so along, it'd
be 63.1 MHz.
So if I had an antenna and could
hear all these different
frequencies and how strong the
signal was, I'd get a profile
of the proton distribution from
foot to head.
So just like we did with the
X-rays scanning down.
I now know how much water there
is at different places
along the height of the body, or
the length of the body.
What did we want to do next?
Matt?
STUDENT: You do it in a
different direction--
PROFESSOR: So we want to make a
gradient
in a different direction, so I
stop the current in those
green coils and put on yellow
coils with current going that
way, which adds to the big field
on the right.
And then I put other coils over
here, which the current
goes that way and subtracts from
the current from the
field on the left.
And when I do that, I get a
gradient from right to left.
So then I can do a slice and
find out how water is
oriented that way.
And then I can put coils on the
top and bottom, analogous
to these, and get a vertical
gradient, and get it that way.
And in fact, by putting a
certain amount of current in
all these coils at the same
time, different amounts in
different coils, I can make a
slice that goes in any
direction I want to, and find
out how much is there.
So now in three dimensions I can
do one of these
tomographic reconstructions, and
get where the
water is in the body.
Now, much more interesting than
that, which is itself
very powerful, is functional
NMR, or MRI, magnetic
resonance imaging.
Where you locate protons whose
signal strength is being
fiddled with.
So for example, we talked about
relaxation, how fast the
signal goes away.
If you measured this for the
different signals you were
getting, how fast they went
away, then you'd know
something about a difference
from one part of the body to
the other, that the protons in
this part, their signal is
going away rapidly, whereas here
they're not.
So you could get something about
how the protons are
behaving, not just what their
local field is.
So for example, blood oxygen
level dependent or B-O-L-D,
BOLD imaging, you can do this.
And you get a spatial resolution
of about one
millimeter, and a temporal
resolution
of about two seconds.
So every two seconds, you can
get where oxygen is in the
body, unusual amounts of oxygen,
Now, how is that relevant?
Because if you have cell
activity, it increases the
blood oxygen supply, and that
speeds the relaxation, how
fast the signal goes away.
So now, these are very weak
signals.
So the way you tell something
about them, is to take a
difference.
Where did we see a difference
map before?
Do you remember?
Remember when we look for
bonds in X-ray, we look at the
observed electron density
minus what you'd have for the
atoms. That different signal,
tells you how it shifted for
bonds.
Well, you do a similar kind of
thing here.
You get a difference map.
Now, this is a bunch of
different
slices through the brain.
And what's lit up is where
there's relaxation.
That is, where there's oxygen,
where the brain cells are
active under one circumstance,
minus how active they are
under some other circumstance.
It's a difference.
So the brain is working harder
when it's in one
state than the other.
Now, what are the two states?
It's the subject being shown
donuts minus the signal when
the subject is being shown car
keys.
So these are places where the
brain lights up when it sees
donuts, but doesn't light up
when it sees car keys.
Now, this particular subject had
recently been fed.
And they did it also for someone
who had not been fed,
who was fasting.
And their brain really lit up
when they saw
donuts versus car keys.
So you can imagine that this is
very, very popular with
psychologists and so on, people
interested in brain and
all sorts of things, where you
can use this trick of
differences to see where
something's happening in one
case versus another.
So that's MRI, and, of course,
it's not fundamentally our
business here to talk about MRI.
Except, we want to see things
happening in molecules.
Now, why can't we do exactly the
same trick with molecules
to find out where protons are in
a molecule?
How do we know that something is
here, rather than here,
rather than here in the brain?
We establish a magnetic gradient
so that you get a
different field here and here,
and you get different
frequencies.
And you can distinguish where it
is in the brain.
What's the problem with doing
that for a molecule, and
looking at different protons in
molecules?
What's the difference between my
brain and a molecule?
There are lots of differences,
but one of them is, that I hope
my brain is an awful lot
bigger than a molecule.
So you can't establish a
gradient big enough across the
small dimensions of a molecule,
so that protons in
different regions will have
different frequencies.
Within any one molecule it
should all be the same field
for practical purposes.
So we can't do this trick, or
can we?
So we want to locate protons
within molecules.
And now we want to have, not a
gradient, we want to have a
uniform field.
If we could make the gradient
big enough, maybe that would
be useful, but we can't make it
big enough.
So let's go the other direction
and make it
absolutely the same everywhere,
a uniform field.
Now, and then what we're going
to do is listen until we hear--
and put up one of these pulses
in-- and hear the frequency
with which these protons--
if there are protons there in
the sample, we'll hear them.
Of course, most organic
substances
have protons in them.
So it doesn't surprise you that
as I scan
the magnetic field--
increasing the magnetic field,
which changes the precession
frequency--
while listening with a radio
that's tuned to just one
frequency, as I go along, at
someplace I'm going to have
the right frequency.
And the protons are going to
give me a signal.
Of course, if I had different
nuclei in there that were
different magnetic strengths,
then I'd get signals at
different places.
But I'm going to only look at--
only listen for protons.
OK, so there it is.
Bingo!
Protons.
Whoop!
Protons again.
There are different signals for
protons.
Not all protons are equivalent.
Now, the difference here,
between this signal and this
signal, and how big the magnetic
field is, is very,
very small.
It differs by only that
fraction,
2.48 parts in a million.
They're almost exactly the same.
But they're a little bit
different, just parts per
million different.
Now, when this was discovered it
was an annoyance for the
physicists who were mostly
interested in things like
measuring how strong the
magnetic moment was, how fast
the precession was for protons.
But they put something in there
that has protons and
they find out there are
different protons.
Which one is the real proton?
So they called this the chemical
shift, because these
differences had something to do
with a chemical
environment.
But this was a gold mine for
chemists, because since the
beginning people have been--
since 1850, at least-- people
have been interested in
chemical structure.
But the only way they could do
it was convert one molecule to
another, count isomers--
as we discussed last semester
with Koerner, and so on--
and try to use logic to figure
out what structure would be
consistent for these various
transformations, chemical
transformations.
And, of course, then there was
X-ray, which really did show
where atoms were.
But here's something that could
work in liquids.
Not everything can be a crystal.
So this looked really, really
promising.
Now, this sample was ethanol.
Now, what do you think the three
different
signals are in ethanol?
Well, one must be the OH.
One must be the H's of the CH2,
and one must be the H's
of the CH3.
Now, doing such an experiment
requires that the field be
very, very uniform, because if,
as you go from one part of
your sample to another, the
field changes by a couple
ppm, then the methyl protons in
this part of
the sample will appear the same
place that the CH2
protons appear in this part of
the sample, or the OH does in
this part of the sample, even if
the gradient across the
sample is only a part per
million or so, a couple parts
per million.
And that's one of the reasons
these peaks are not
infinitely sharp.
One of the reasons they're broad
is that the field isn't
perfectly uniform.
But it's very good.
It's within a fraction of a part
per million.
Now, in the late 1950s, as it
says here, chemistry
departments began buying
commercial NMR spectrometers.
This one was called the Varian
A-60, and it's the one I
learned to operate.
And they had to have fields that
were homogeneous enough to
determine molecular structure.
So they had to have fields that
were different, that
didn't vary by more than a small
part of a part per
million, so that you could tell
things about chemical
shifts and spin-spin splittings,
which we're going
to be talking about in the rest
of this lecture.
But, of course, these things
were expensive and many
different people were using
them, so it was a challenge to
keep the field homogeneous to
obtain sharp lines.
Now, there were knobs in there
that you could turn the
current to coils, to cancel a
gradient in one direction or
another, or another, or another.
And most of them were hidden
behind that door, and the door
said on it, Do Not Open.
Because someone who knew what he
was doing came in at the
beginning of the day and turned
all those knobs just
right, so the field was very
uniform.
And if anybody else came in and
twiddled them, then the
next guy to come in was really
up a creek.
So do not touch these gradient
knobs.
In fact, there was one there,
the y gradient, which would
have its own special sign, Do
not touch this.
Now, this was fine, but across
New Haven... or across the Long
Island Sound here, you see the
smokestacks of Port Jefferson
and the medical building at
State University in New York
at Stony Brook.
And there was a physical chemist
at Stony Brook who
fiddled with them.
His name was Paul Lauterbur.
And in 1972 he would take over
this machine every night, and
he'd just wreck the field
homogeneity.
And, of course, late at night
before he left, or early
morning, he would turn all the
knobs back, because he was
really an expert at NMR. But the
reason he did this was to
establish gradients in different
directions so that
he could locate--
he had a sample tube, and he
filled it
with D20, not protons.
And in it he put two capillary
tubes that had water in them.
So he did exactly the kind of
experiment we
were talking about.
And in Nature in 1973, he
published this, where he
scanned vertically and got this,
scanned horizontally and
got this, scanned at 45 degrees
or -45 degrees and got those,
and could find out where these
water samples were inside D2O.
And he called that
zeugmatography, but the name
didn't catch on.
But the good news was that 30
years later he got the Nobel
Prize in Physiology or Medicine,
for inventing MRI.
And that's what he worked on the
rest of his life.
So it was a chemist who invented
MRI.
So there are lots and lots of
magnetic resonance
spectrometers.
And I already showed you some
X-ray diffractomers around,
which have put classical
structure proof by chemical
transformation, the kind of
thing that we talked about
Koerner doing,
and even IR, mostly out of
business, although there are
still things for which IR is as
good or even better than
NMR. And, in fact, there was a
Yale--
before I came here, there was a
organic chemistry professor
who was in the field called
natural products, where the
job was to take something that
came from nature and figure
out what its structure was.
And the way to do it, in those
days, was to do these chemical
transformations and try to make
it from something or make
it into something whose
structure you knew.
So these were great puzzles, and
it was
really a big operation.
But when NMR came along, he
abandoned organic chemistry
and took up fundamental research
on quantum theory.
And in fact, later he became a
professional studio
photographer.
He was just wiped out by NMR
coming along, which is the way
people know structures now.
We haven't really talked about
that much, about how people
knew-- we've talked about
different structures, but not
really how people figured them
out, except
when they used X-ray.
But this is an even more common
way of determining
structures routinely, is
spectroscopy.
And in particular, nowadays,
magnetic resonance
spectroscopy.
So a couple of years ago I took
a tour through the
department and took photographs
of magnetic
resonance spectrometers to show
you here.
So across from your lab you may
have noticed this door
which says Chemical
Instrumentation Center, and it
says warning over here, about
magnetic fields, so if you
have a pacemaker, be careful.
And you go inside there, and
some of these have now been
moved since I took the pictures,
but you see these
things sticking up like here,
and here.
And if you go around, you see
these big cans, WARNING:
strong magnetic field.
Here's another one.
That's a 500 MHz spectrometer.
Here's a 500 MHz spectrometer.
Here's a 600 MHz spectrometer.
Here's another 600 MHz
spectrometer.
And out in the courtyard, behind
your lab, there's this
special little building that was
constructed specially for
a big magnet.
And it has this one, which is an
800 MHz spectrometer,
which turns out to be 8 to the
third power.
That is 512 times as sensitive
as a 100 MHz
spectrometer, not to mention
other advantages that we're
going to talk about below.
Now, why is it 8 cubed?
It's because of the Boltzmann
factor.
Remember, this signal comes
because there are more that
point with the field than
against the field.
We only see the difference
between those two.
And if you have a bigger energy
difference, you'll get
a bigger population difference.
So you get an eightfold factor
from that.
But the energy quantum that
you're dealing with, in going
from one level to another,
becomes eight times as big.
That's an advantage in your
signal.
And the sensitivity of the
electronics, when it's eight
times bigger, is also better.
So all these things go together
to make it 500 times
better, and even more than 500
times better when you consider
what we'll talk about soon, the
chemical shift advantage.
So that's why one pays the big
bucks to have a
machine like that.
Here are just some others that I
took around.
And now by the cross hall there,
next to your lab when you
walk down there on this side of
it, there's a room that has
electron paramagnetic resonance
spectrometers.
So this is a much smaller
magnet, not one of these big
liquid helium cooled things.
And the reason is that this is
to study free radicals, which
have magnetic electrons.
Mostly electrons come in pairs
and their magnetisms cancel.
But in certain molecules, free
radicals, there's an odd
electron, whose magnetism is
detectable.
So this is to study free
radicals.
And the electron magnet is 660
times
stronger than the proton.
So you don't need such a big
field to make it precess.
So you can use just 0.3 Tesla
instead of several Tesla for
electron paramagnetic resonance.
So there are two of those
spectrometers.
And in fact, we don't have one
of these, but there's now
commercially available a 1000
MHz spectrometer, which
is 23.5 Tesla.
And at the Florida State
University National High Field
Magnet Lab, there's a field
that's pulsed
that goes to 45 Tesla.
And it's a national lab.
You don't pay to use it.
But you have to have a great
experiment to be assigned time
to do things there.
So there are lots of these
things around.
Now let's go back and see why
it's so good.
OK, we have these three signals,
and as we said, we're
interested in which peak is
which set of protons.
Now, how do we know which is
which?
Can anybody see a way of
figuring out which is the CH3,
which is the CH2, and which is
the OH?
Any guesses?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The size of the peaks.
PROFESSOR: Ah!
If you have twice as many
protons, there should be twice
as strong a signal.
You measure the strength of the
signal by how much area is
under it, by integrating it.
So if we measure the integrals,
we see they're in
the ratio of 1:2:3, so it's
clear that that's the 1,
that's the 2, and that's the 3.
Now, we couldn't do this in IR,
because we had these
normal modes,
an had for example, C=O.
And remember, as the C=O
vibrated, something else
vibrated at the same time, and
other things, and they could
cancel or reinforce.
So the signal intensities were
very, very different for
different groups.
But here the protons are all
essentially exactly the same.
They differ only by a part per
million, or a few parts per
million, so the intensities are
proportional to the number
of protons, because the
difference is so subtle.
So you can count protons by the
area under these peaks.
That's what it says here.
The number is proportional to
the number protons because
they're so similar, not like IR
peaks.
Now, how can you use this?
Here was one of the very first
uses of a subtle organic
chemistry question.
This was an advertisement by the
Varian Corporation in
1955, who were trying to sell
those machines I showed you,
that the guy over at--
Paul Lauterbur messed up the
field on every night.
So this was 20, the use of
integrated
intensities in structural
analysis.
So there's a question of the
structure of C7H8, whether
it's this or this.
And notice that those two are
related to one another,
because if we shifted the
electrons like that, one would
go to the other.
So you could imagine them going
back and forth by an
electrocyclic reaction.
And the question is, which is it
really?
Well, you could try to figure
out by chemical
transformation, and people did
that.
So which is it?
Well, let's try ozonolysis.
Now, do you remember what
happens with ozonolysis and
then oxidation?
You cleave C=C double bonds and
make carbonyl groups there, an
acid, make a carboxylic acid
group when you add the H2O2.
So these would give different
products.
Notice that on the left, you
would cleave three bonds, on
the right, you'd cleave only two
double bonds.
So on the left, you would get
that diacid. On the right,
you'd get the diacid that has
two more carbons.
Now, in fact, that acid on the
right was known.
It's called cis-caronic acid,
and that's what you got.
So what's the conclusion?
The conclusion is that the
structure must be B, not A. So
that's a classical structure
proof by chemical
transformation.
But here's a completely
different way
of going about it.
Take the NMR spectrum and count
the protons.
So the group on the left there
are protons that are attached
to double bonded carbons, and on
the right, to
single bonded carbons.
And now, notice that the
compound B has
four of each kind.
But compound A has six of one
kind and two of the other.
And if you integrate, you find
that those
ratios are 2.9:1, 3:1.
So which is it?
It must be A that you're taking
the spectrum of.
That's the one that's 3:1.
So it must be that that's the
structure, but then how do you
explain this misleading chemical
transformation?
It must be that there's an
equilibrium between these two
things that lies to the left, so
when you take the spectrum
that's the stuff you see, that's
most of the material.
But it's not as reactive with
ozone as the
stuff on the right.
So that little bit of stuff on
the right is what reacts with
ozone and gives the product.
So the chemical transformation
was misleading.
And this is the kind of thing
that made this Yale natural
products organic chemistry
professor pull out his hair
and become a quantum chemist,
and then a studio
photographer, that you couldn't
do what he was
trained to do anymore.
So spectroscopy took over in
determining structure, and
we're going to talk a little bit
about how you do this.
Now, Chemistry 220 website has a
bunch of NMR problems.
There are 40 problems there, and
I took this from one of
them and fiddled with it a
little bit.
And in fact, let me just see, I
think I left an extra--
well, I'll go through here and--
there's going to be an extra
slide in here.
So we can integrate.
And see that there are 2 and 3,
and 3.
So we know that the 2 must be
that CH2, but there are two
CH3 groups, one is one and one
is the other.
That's at low resolution, where
the
field isn't so uniform.
But if you make the field
really, really uniform, if you
tweak those knobs just right, so
that the peaks don't get
broadened by having different
fields in different parts of
the sample, and in fact, spin
the sample, so that a given
molecule actually is going
around and sampling different
parts to average the field, to
make it even more uniform,
then you see this thing with
sharp peaks.
So it's the same 3, 3, 2, but
they look a
little different here.
So the peak width is about three
parts per billion, and
that's just, as you see, a
single peak there.
But this next one is a little
different.
That's a triplet, 1:2:1.
So that's one of those CH3
groups, but which CH3 group?
Oh, pardon me, I got it
backwards.
This was a CH3 group, and it
turns out to be this one.
This CH3 group is split into
three, and it's that one.
Now, why is it not a single
peak?
What's different?
OK, well, that splitting is
0.029 parts per million.
I obviously blew it up in order
to be able to see it
clearly here.
And this is a 250 MHz spectrum.
So it means that splitting, the
difference in frequency,
of protons in one environment or
the other, is 7.3 Hz.
And it's exactly the same there,
7.3 Hz.
Now, if you look here, that's a
quartet.
And those are 7.3 Hz as well.
Now, what's that last signal,
this little
tiny one down here?
Well, notice that the solvent is
CDCl3.
Now, why would they pay the
bucks, the big bucks, to get
deuterium rather than just using
normal chloroform,
CHCl3, for a solvent.
What would it look like if the
solvent were CHCl3?
You'd have an enormous peak from
the solvent, that
hydrogen of the solvent.
It would wash out the other
things.
So you make it deuterium.
But it's not 100% deuterium.
There's a tiny, tiny amount of
protium in there.
So that tiny signal comes from a
little bit
of CH3 [correction:CHCI3] in the
solvent.
So the 90 degree pulse makes the
spinning nuclei broadcast
a frequency that tells their
local magnetic field, in a
uniform field.
Now, there's the big uniform
field.
But what the nucleus sees is an
effective local magnetic
field, which is, of course, the
big field-- that's mostly
it-- but little, little tiny
differences due to the
chemical environment.
And let's see how we do it.
OK, just to back up at first,
you could make the applied
field inhomogeneous, as an MRI.
And then the field can be, for
example, 2 Tesla, 30,000
Gauss, with a gradient of 4
Gauss per
centimeter for human samples.
And if you have a tiny thing,
you could
make a bigger gradient.
So for small animals you can get
50 Gauss per centimeter
and do the imaging that we
talked about.
But in chemistry it's different.
In chemistry, you make it really
homogeneous, so the
only differences come not from
where the proton is in the
sample, but from where it is in
a molecule.
And now we're interested in a
molecular field that's added
to or subtracted from the big
field.
And mostly it's subtracted from,
as you'll see.
So these molecular fields then
tell you about the molecular
environment, these tiny shifts.
So there are two sources of
these local magnetic fields,
besides the enormous big field
that you put on.
One is electrons orbiting.
Now, the electrons come in pairs
that tend to orbit in
opposite directions, so they
tend to cancel.
But there's a little bit of
excess, for reasons we don't
need to go on to, of one
orbiting over the other.
So you get effects from electron
orbiting.
And the magnitude of this shift
is about 12 parts per
million for protons, or 200 ppm
for carbon,
the range of values you can get
from that.
Which is-- so this is grossly
exaggerated.
It should be only parts per
million of this, not, you
know, like a 20th or something
like that, or a 10th.
OK, so one thing about the
environment is how many
electrons are around doing this
orbiting?
The other thing is there are
other magnetic nuclei nearby
who have fields, too.
So if you're this proton, or
listening for this proton, its
field is not only going to be
the big field, not only what's
coming from the electrons
orbiting, but also what's
coming from other nuclei that
are in the vicinity, being
oriented either this way or this
way.
OK, and those we measure in Hz,
and you'll see why we
measure one in ppm, and the
other in
Hz very soon.
So anyhow, when you add all
those things together, you get
an effective field.
And that's what determines the
frequency of the signal you're
going to hear.
So first we're going to talk
about the chemical shift, what
happens from orbiting.
So electron orbiting gives this
little red B, but the
reason the electrons orbit is
because of the applied field.
And the bigger the applied
field,
the bigger the orbiting.
So that says the red field is
proportional to the blue field.
If you spent the money to get a
bigger magnet, you'd get
twice as much orbiting, so the
red would be twice as big.
So that says that what you
measure then is a fractional
thing, because it's not a
standard difference.
It depends on how big your
magnet is.
If you make your magnet twice as
big, the shift is twice as
big, the red field is twice as
big.
So it's a fraction of the big
one.
So you measure it in parts per
million, in a fractional unit
rather than in an absolute unit,
like an energy unit,
like Hz.
OK, so here's a scale of parts
per million.
Let's see what different values
we have. Now, the
standard that's used it's called
TMS, tetramethylsilane.
Now, why use such a weird
molecule as your standard?
Well, it's a small molecule and
it's volatile.
So you can add a drop to your
sample, but you can easily get
it out again if you want to
recover your sample, because
it evaporates easily.
Now, it has four CH3 groups, but
they're all identically
situated, so it will just give
one peak rather than a more
complicated molecule, so that's
good.
But the thing that's really
special is that the silicon
is, being a metal, is partially
plus, and the methyl
is largely minus, which means
there are more electrons
around the protons, which means
there's a bigger shielding.
This B is bigger than it would
be if there were fewer
electrons around.
So it shifted all the way to one
end of the spectrum, so it
doesn't overlap other things
that you might
have in your sample.
So you have a standard, then,
that you can use with high
electron density around the
protons, which defines 0.
And now, you get another peak
from your sample, and see
where it is compared to this.
For example, if you have a
carboxylic acid, the H on a
carboxylic acid is way what's
called downfield.
Why?
Why is it very different from
the hydrogen in TMS?
Anybody see why the COOH
hydrogen might be different?
The environment of it?
The OH is electron withdrawing,
especially with the carbonyl
group on it.
So the electrons get sucked away
from the hydrogen.
You don't have as much of that
red shielding effect, so it's
shifted way down to the
other end.
So on the right, it's said to
be shielded.
That is, the electrons around
the proton cancel the big
field, but only a teeny bit of
it, only a
few parts per million.
And it's called upfield, and
it's also a place where
there's high electron density.
And it's called a low chemical
shift.
This scale is the chemical shift
numbers, and that's
defined as zero, so it's a very
low number.
And it's also low frequency,
because we have lots of
electrons relatively big value
here.
There is very small, relatively
small, magnet
effective field, relatively
small.
So a low precession frequency,
not such a big field.
By contrast, the OH is called
deshielded, downfield, low
electron density, high chemical
shift, and high frequency.
Now, if you have a proton that's
attached to a normal
carbon, not one that's attached
to silicon, which is
giving electrons away, then it
comes around 1, or
between 1/2 and 2.
And these were found just by
putting different known
samples in and seeing where the
peaks came.
But if you have oxygen, halogen,
or nitrogen attached
to the carbon, in the same way
that silicon donated electrons
to carbon, these electronegative
atoms take
electrons from the carbon, which
take electrons from the
hydrogen, which make B smaller,
which shift it downfield.
So in that region, between 2.5
and 4.5.
If the carbon, to which the
hydrogen is attached, is
itself attached to a carbon, not
to one of these
electronegative elements, but
that carbon has oxygen on it,
then the oxygen is sucking
electrons from carbon, from
carbon, from hydrogen, so it's
shifted down a little bit.
So a hydrogen on a carbon
attached to a carbonyl is in
between there.
If you have a carbon attached to
a double bond, it's shifted
down still further.
Now, why should a hydrogen
attached to a double bond be
different from a carbon with a
double bond, be different from
a hydrogen attached to a carbon
with only single bonds?
What difference? Mimi?
STUDENT: The pi bond?
PROFESSOR: It's not the--
well, actually, to tell you the
truth, it probably is the
pi bond, but that's not the
explanation that people
usually give.
What other difference?
What difference is there in the
sigma system?
Lauren?
STUDENT: Hybridization?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me.
STUDENT: Hybridization.
PROFESSOR: The hybridization,
right?
This is an sp squared, more s,
more electron withdrawing.
Whereas these carbons are
sp cubed, so as you pull
electrons to the carbon, away
from the
hydrogen, you shift down.
That makes sense.
In fact, this, you might expect,
would be the same.
It's shifted even a little
further down.
All these things were discovered
empirically, just
by putting known samples in and
finding
out where they come.
And then an aldehyde is, you
won't be surprised to hear, is
still further down, because it
has the oxygen-- it's not only
double bonded, it has an
oxygen pulling away.
So all these things more or less
make sense, in terms of
electron withdrawal, or donation
to the hydrogen.
But in fact, it's a little more
subtle than that.
Now ROH is funny, because it can
come at lots of different
positions, depending on
concentration, and depending
on temperature.
Why would concentration have
anything to do with it?
Why would it have come at a
different place if
you had more ROH?
Lauren?
STUDENT: The hydrogen bonding
between molecules.
PROFESSOR: If you have hydrogen
bonding
and that affects the chemical
shift, the higher
concentration, more hydrogen
bonding, higher temperature,
less hydrogen bonding.
So OH comes at lots of different
positions depending
on those factors.
But you can already see from
this, that if you take a
spectrum and see peaks in
different positions, you can
try to say, aha!
This looks like it has hydrogens
that are just
attached to carbons that are all
single bonded.
It has hydrogens on double
bonded carbons, blah, blah.
You measure the integral and see
how many of each kind
there are, and you can then do
puzzles, like the ones in that
web page that I mentioned, to
try to figure out what
structures are.
Now, let's see if you've learned
from this.
Where should you expect the
hydrogen that is attached to
the carbon of an acetylene?
Where would you expect it to
come?
What's special?
Noelle, you got any idea on
this?
What's special about it?
STUDENT: The triple bond.
PROFESSOR: Can't hear.
PROFESSOR: The triple bond.
So now, how is the triple bond
going to affect things?
STUDENT: Hybridization.
PROFESSOR: It will affect the
hybridization, in what way?
STUDENT: Will it be deshielding?
PROFESSOR: It'll be sp.
It'll be an sp hybrid, which is
more electron withdrawing,
than sp squared, than
sp cubed.
So it should be pulling
electrons away, deshielding,
as you say, because the
electrons are shielding, so it
should shift to the left,
compared to the double bond
ones, right?
Wrong.
It actually comes up there.
So there's more to it than what
we're saying.
Now, what is this more to it?
Unfortunately, the clock has
run, so you're going to have
to wait for tomorrow to find
that out.